ta vie ta valise ou pas déjà
ma valise mec je sais même pas si tout
va rentrer dedans à un mois de vacances
que ça fait combien de temps que tu as
pas pris un mois de vacances
je crois aux siens je crois aussi bien
aux films de fou le plus possible les
vacances
pour plein de souvenirs ont filmé avec
nos fans des trucs et peut-être que ça
rentrera dans quelque chose plus tard tu
vois mais au moins on aura une trace de
ces un mois de vacances que l'on prend
pour la première fois notre vie tu vois
des zones rurales
[Musique]
toc toc tu fais chier vaudin sèche peut
pas percé ap ce bouton
faire chier pas pour traverser des tu le
sais mais pour tenter par des zoos que
j'étais vexé tirera bien prévert ou deux
arrêtez de vouloir sourire sur les
photos ça me fait chier quand on fallait
ressortir toi que j'ai veillé quelle
époque les animaux quand on était tous
vote s'était pas tout à fait paisible au
revoir
on a les mots ce n'est pas pour acheter
des parts comme il y avait deux thèmes
la sucré et le salé
nettement à part la forme
sortir avec paty flemme de persos
plastique devant la mort
étudiez l'afrique du temps d'aimer
acheté un ticket quand je te fera dès
qu'ils entrent pas pu entendre
les photos
ça me fait ch et canton valait ressortir
toi que j'ai vieillit
l'animateur n'en n'était pas à cette
époque j'avais des réserves
comme ça tu grandis tu deviens et grit
est devenu le tocard qui traînent très
tard sur des sites et c'est trop tard
faut draguer toutes ces belles filles
oui c'est dommage d'être spectateur de
ta vie salut mexique
petite voix dans sa tête est un peu
et je montre aux autres que tu acceptes
un peu de
[Musique]
temps
bon
les gars
[Musique]
doit
arrêter de vouloir sourire sur les
photos
ça fait chier quand on fallait ressortir
toi que j'ai vieillit quel est votre ami
roma on était tous marre de cette époque
où j'ai fait des abdos et moi une coupe
au bol arrêtez de vouloir faire sourire
sur les photos d'autres
ça fait cher qu'en magasin
et qu'elle n'est pas les animaux d'or
comme on était tous matt cette époque
que j'avais fait des abdos mois une
coupole
[Musique]